con apenas treinta y tres años va a ir
en forma parte de una generación de
mujeres que ha dado vida al mundo de la
ciencia en panamá somos pacientes
tenemos somos muy dedicadas como mujeres
cuando tenemos hijos nos toca hacer
tantos roles a la vez eso es ventajoso
dentro de laboratorio porque nos toca
hacer tantas cosas en un tiempo
determinado marín es pionera en el
estudio de células madre una llegada del
coi 19 su trabajo se orientó hacia la
regeneración pulmonar y la posible
transmisión o no el virus de una madre
embarazada a su hijo es lo primero es
analizar si la placenta tiene el virus
que es o el departamento de virología
luego de esta misma placenta y extraer
el material genético de estar positivo
la placenta
y entender cuál es el abecedario
genético de ese virus o sea secuenciar
el virus
la labor de mailín y de su equipo ha
sido reconocida por la unesco pero es el
deseo de contribuir con una solución a
un problema mundial que mantiene al
equipo de pie
una gran responsabilidad no equivocarse
no equivocarse y saber cómo solucionar
todas esas son cosas que hay que uno
tiene que estar pensando porque al final
del día tú quieres ayudar a una persona
que quiere ver a un paciente
ayudar a pacientes pero también cuidar a
los suyos es el reto cotidiano de mayrín
quien tiene cinco hijos
es difícil cuesta mucho el balance de
ser madre esposa y científica pero creo
que lo llevamos bien de la mano los dos
y así con el apoyo de su esposo también
científico mayrín logra ser parte de un
número cada vez más grande de
científicas panameñas en un país donde
la inversión en la ciencia no alcanza el
1 por ciento de su presupuesto